[Music]
[Applause]
so the road to Civil War picks up with
the New Avengers one shot the Illuminati
and this comic book is particularly
important in the realm of Marvel Comics
not necessarily because it sets us on
the road to understanding how the Civil
War really kind of develops and begins
to unfold but because this comic gives
us the backstory of the Illuminati and
the Illuminati were introduced to us and
the New Avengers with volume 1 issue
number 1 but we didn't really know how
it was that the the Illuminati had come
together they simply were just there
they were first introduced during the
six part storyline the breakout and then
of course they came across the
reintroduction of the century in the
Marvel Comics in 2005 but we didn't know
how this took place we didn't know how
the Illuminati had formed if any
meetings had taken place or anything
like that this one-shot gave us that
backstory and what we see is that after
the events of the kree-skrull war which
was a war between the Kree and the
scroll to alien species that had been
warring for millions of years Tony Stark
had really kind of come to the
understanding that had the most
prominent leaders I guess in the
superhero community shared information
that each of them had individually the
conflict could have gone a much
different way as opposed to really kind
of impacting earth and coming as close
to Earth as it had they could have
really kind of executed preemptive
strikes so that it never really came as
close to Earth as it did and so he
organizes this sort of leadership
gathering this sort of meeting in
Wakanda and what we see is that Tony
Stark himself as the de facto leader of
the Avengers so to speak we see Charles
Xavier as a leader of the x-men a Black
Bolt as a leader of the Inhumans dr.
strange as the sorcerer supreme Reed
Richards of the Fantastic Four and aimer
the Submariner of the kingdom of
Atlantis really kind of coming together
and really kind of I guess maybe mulling
over this idea of forming a kind of
secret government so to speak now they
wouldn't really form a government and
the traditional sense that is to say
they would impose laws on the superhuman
community they would really just kind of
be the hidden hand a baton behind a lot
of things that take place and with you
see that's really kind of playing out
initially people are not very receptive
to the idea
a secret government or an Illuminati and
in fact Charles Xavier voices his
concerns and says this is really kind of
the base fear that virtually everyone
who has a fear of superhumans has
they're afraid that at some point along
the line now this exact kind of thing
will form Tonie starting of course
combats this and says it is done with
the best of intentions but as we've seen
in the past sometimes the best of
intentions turn into the worst-case
scenarios so ultimately the group really
kind of decides to go along with it of
course black panther chooses not to
accept the invitation and over the
course of this comic we see the
Illuminati executing various plans we of
course see the Illuminati make the
decision to kick the Incredible Hulk out
of the planet Earth and send him to a
different planet just because of the
fact that due to the his violent nature
and Bruce banners for the most part
inability to control the Incredible Hulk
he really presents more of a danger than
virtually any other earthbound character
at that particular point in time the
real kind of nail in the coffin I guess
the real kind of lead-up to the Civil
War is when we see the third meeting of
the Illuminati coming together and at
this time the House of M storyline has
come to an end and so Charles Xavier is
missing no one knows where he is and we
see that Tony Stark presents the
Illuminati with a bill with the
superhuman Registration Act that is
going to go before Congress and
initially he believes they should side
with it now from here we pick up with
the Fantastic Four issues number 536 and
537 but unlike the New Avengers
Illuminati storyline we don't really see
anything involving the superhuman
Registration Act for the most part what
we actually see is that Thor's hammer
which had previously belonged to Thor
who most people at this point had a
assume to have been dead falls to the
planet Earth and lands in Oklahoma we
see the Fantastic Four receive a
distress column when they arrive they
see a military base which is being
overrun by dr. doom and his doombots
over the course of these two comics we
ultimately see that the goal of Doctor
Doom is to attain the hammer of Thor and
ultimately he fails and in kind of a bit
of humor towards the end we see that the
thing Ben Grimm tries to pick up the
hammer of Thor and of course is
unsuccessful from here we pick up with
the last three issues that are part of
the road to civil war storyline which is
the amazing spider-man vol 2 issues
number 529 to 531
and this I would say is probably the
most important part of the road to civil
war storyline what we see here are a
couple things taking place the first is
that Tony Stark who has formed a very
close friendship with Peter Parker
presents him with a new spider-man suit
and this new spider-man suit is really
kind of intriguing here what's really
amazing about this is that it allows for
a multitude of abilities that spider-man
simply just didn't have before he can
change his suit and to camouflage so he
can appear with virtually any other
spider-man suit that he has ever worn he
can in fact have a spider-man suit
camouflage itself in such a way that it
looks like he's not wearing anything at
all so that he doesn't have to walk
around with what appears to be a
spider-man suit under his normal
clothing he will simply just appear
wearing and over shirt and maybe a
t-shirt underneath or something like
that we also see that there are some
appendages that extend themselves from
the back of the suit and these
appendages allow him lines of sight and
they also allow some measure of a
physical attack but as Tony Stark tells
capitals I'm sorry to tell spider-man
the arms really aren't designed to be a
full-on attack kind of attribute and so
they're very fragile and they can easily
be destroyed and we see of course that
Spiderman really kind of takes this suit
to to the streets and really kind of
tests it for what it can do and we see
these able to glide with the suit and
and various things like that but the
real kind of meet imitators of the road
to Civil War really kind of picks up
with issue number 530 and into 531 and
what we see with these issues and
including 529 is that Tony Stark comes
to spider-man and asked for his help but
will not tell him what it is that he's
asking for his help with unless he
swears to secrecy that he will not tell
anybody what it is that's going on and
ultimately a Tony Stark presents Peter
Parker with an early copy of the
superhuman Registration Act and
following towards the end of the series
we see that basically Peter Parker and
Tony Stark appear before Congress in an
attempt to assuage them from the idea of
passing the superhuman Registration Act
we see some impassionate speeches here
we see how Congress comes along with the
idea of saying that people who drive
vehicles have to be licensed people who
fly planes have to be licensed and of
course Peter Parker counters this by
saying that those individuals chose that
career path they chose to become pilots
they chose to become doctors and lawyers
and
and the like people who became
superpower superheroes really didn't
choose that their powers just sort of
came upon them and they chose the best
road they knew how to take to be
responsible you know he really kind of
touches back on the words that Uncle Ben
had taught him that with great power
comes great responsibility
ultimately as the meetings begin to come
to an end we see that Tony Stark is
assaulted by cat or by a titanium man
and after being assaulted by titanium
man Peter Parker really kind of has
speculation that Tony Stark orchestrated
the whole thing Tony Stark isn't
necessarily direct at first but
ultimately he says no I did not organize
this but at the end of spider-man issue
number 531 we see that ultimately it was
Tony Stark that orchestrated the entire
attack and as we begin to come to a
close as we begin to see the final pages
of amazing spider-man ball you to issue
number 531 we see the Peter Parker's in
front of the TV and falls asleep to a
newscast which is ultimately the event
that sets off the entire civil war
storyline where the new Warriors are
involved in a conflict in Stamford
Connecticut that cost the lives of
somewhere around 600 people and really
begins to turn the tide in terms of
public support for a superhuman
Registration Act welcome to the weekly
poll your number one source for comic
book discussions I'm Benny from comic
story in okay what's going on what's
going on guys this is Rob I'm from
Marvel explain and this is David
[Music]